Speaker 1: Today, I'm going to be speaking
with Dr. Mary Claire O'Brien, who's a professor
of emergency medicine at Wake Forest University
School of Medicine, who was the leading medical
expert informing the FDA decision to remove
pre-mixed alcoholic energy drinks from U.S.
markets back in 2010.
It's really great to have you on today.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 2: Thank you so much for inviting
me.
Speaker 1: So maybe to start with energy drinks
in general, when we talk about what they are,
I think most people understand it's a stimulant
of sorts.
Some of them have caffeine, which we're used
to getting when we drink coffee.
What exactly is it always caffeine or are
there other stimulant stimulant elements in
these energy drinks?
And how does the dosage compare to a cup of
coffee, for example?
Speaker 2: So those are all very good questions.
So from a physiologic standpoint, energy is
calories that you consume.
But all of us want understand that really
what energy drinks do is deliver caffeine
in one or various forms, either added as a
chemical or in guarana or yerba monte or other
things where there are additives that are
essentially just other forms of caffeine.
Brewed black coffee has about 30 before the
average homebrew.
Black coffee has about 100 milligrams of caffeine
in it.
And that's a good strong cup of home brewed
black coffee and a cola that you would buy
over the counter has about 35 or 50 milligrams
of caffeine in it.
Energy drinks are very variable in the amount
of caffeine that they contain because of a
quirk of an FDA situation in which they are
not regulated as a beverage by the Food and
Drug Administration.
So you can't pick up a cola on a shelf at
12 ounce cola that has more than 70 parts,
70 milligrams of caffeine in it, which is
200 parts per million.
But an energy drink, oddly enough, is considered
a dietary supplement by the FDA and they are
not regulated.
An energy drink may contain anywhere from
100 to 150 to 200 milligrams of caffeine.
Those little bitty energy shots that people
pick up all the time have 200 milligrams of
caffeine.
So in two ounces called one chug, you're drinking
the equivalent of two very strong cups of
hot black coffee that you would otherwise
take your time to sip.
And you get that jolt of caffeine right away.
Speaker 1: When we talk about the feeling
of I have coffee and I feel awake and energized,
sometimes there's the belief that you are
getting something.
But but what's happening really is that the
caffeine is blocking the sleep pressure that
builds up.
If I recall correctly from Michael Pollan's
book, it's the buildup of adenosine that over
time makes us feel tired.
So the caffeine is sort of like it's delaying
fear.
Feeling tired, really, Right.
That's what it does.
Speaker 2: Yes.
So caffeine, although we call it a stimulant,
is not a stimulant.
What it does is it makes you feel less sleepy.
Right now, for those of us who are sleepy,
who want to be stimulated, the feeling of
having caffeine and waking up, we all are
pretty familiar with it.
Most of us drink some caffeinated beverage
in the morning.
However, it is in fact not stimulating you.
It's blocking the chemical that's naturally
released in your body that makes you feel
sleepy.
So caffeine makes you feel less sleepy.
It does not stimulate you unless, of course,
you talk about the way that it potentially
could stimulate, let's say, your heart rate
or your blood pressure when large quantities
are consumed or when normal quantities are
consumed, or what would generally be regarded
as safe in susceptible individuals, people
who might be sensitive to the effects of the
caffeine.
Speaker 1: So before we get on to the energy
drink health stuff, how should we be thinking
about what you just described?
Is it different than how something like Adderall
or amphetamines work?
Speaker 2: 100%, yes.
Caffeine basically makes you a little it makes
you less sleepy.
It is not an addictive substance in the way
that we would think about perhaps methamphetamine.
And I'm not sure that for the average person,
the difference between being less sleep sleepy
and being mildly stimulated makes a whole
lot of practical difference.
It does, however, have important implications
when we start talking about mixing energy
drinks with alcohol and the idea that if you
take an energy drink or consume large amounts
of caffeine with alcohol, that it will stimulate
you.
And the fact that you feel a little bit less
sleepy means that the other neuropsychiatric
effects of alcohol and motor effects of alcohol
are likewise reduced when they are not.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So before we introduce the alcohol part, what
are the risks of just extremely high doses
of caffeine?
You know, I remember a story of someone who
owned a coffee shop and for their cold brew
they used to concentrate and one day somebody
forgot that it's supposed to be watered down
and all of a sudden the caffeine dose in a
cup is ten x what it's supposed to be, whether
it's a caffeine in coffee or an energy drink,
what are the risks of too much caffeine too
quickly?
Speaker 2: So the answer to that question
has to be preceded by it depends on whom are
the effects.
Okay.
So in healthy individuals who are not otherwise
susceptible, the FDA says we shouldn't consume
more than 400 milligrams of caffeine.
So let's say four cups of coffee.
Less than that is generally regarded as safe
unless you have a preexisting condition, which
you might not know about.
But anyway, that's what generally for a healthy,
non-pregnant non nursing adult, that's considered
safe.
Speaker 1: Over what period of time?
Speaker 2: In one day?
In a day.
Okay.
Yeah.
For pregnant or nursing individuals, that
number is 200 milligrams.
So no more than two cups of coffee.
And it's not saying that that is a good idea,
but it's saying we think that's generally
regarded as safe in adolescence.
It's 100 milligrams.
So that's a strong cup of coffee.
But most of us aren't going to give our 12
year olds a strong cup of coffee in the morning
before they go to school.
But that's the number, the limit that's sort
of been set by the FDA.
And then for children, there is absolutely
no safe level whatsoever.
Zero.
American Academy of Pediatrics, even though
they state that 30 to 50% of adolescents drink
energy drinks, there is absolutely no level
of safety established in children.
Adolescents should not drink energy drinks.
Children should not drink.
Energy drinks.
Hard.
Stop.
Speaker 1: And when we talk about the negative
health consequences, that having more than
that 400 milligrams can have, what are they?
Speaker 2: So I think about most of us who've
had a little bit too much caffeine or had
it too late at night have experienced jitteriness,
insomnia, nervousness, sometimes at higher
doses ringing in the ears.
It can cause stomach upset, nausea.
There are it can cause flushing.
It's also curiously thought chronic levels
of caffeine ingestion are thought to decrease
calcium absorption.
So one of the things you worry about is over
time, adolescence, women drinking high levels
of caffeine or steady levels of caffeine,
will that predisposed to osteoporosis.
So it definitely interferes with calcium metabolism.
And then in pregnant individuals, high and
or heavy use of caffeine habitually has been
associated with increased risk for miscarriage
and for having babies that are small for gestational
age at birth.
Now, that's all you know, most of us have
been familiar with some of the side effects
that we would get.
But remember, in susceptible individuals,
there are people who can't even drink a single
cup of coffee.
And how do you know that?
You don't know until you get supraventricular
tachycardia.
Now, guess what?
You can only have decaf, right?
Which is not no cath, but much less caffeine.
Speaker 1: So when we introduce the alcohol
component and this could be an energy drink
that is already alcohol plus the caffeine
in the package, it can also be the infamous
Red Bull and vodka.
Right.
I mean, these are also drinks that one can
kind of mix on their own.
What happens when you combine the two?
Speaker 2: So the pre-mixed alcoholic energy
drinks, which is the terminology that was
used, pre-mixed alcoholic energy drinks.
And I won't mention the brands because I don't
want to give them airtime, but they're they
are 100% off the market in the United States.
Right.
And that is because it is very clear that
increasing that mixing caffeine and alcohol,
those prepackaged things, which was never
permitted by the FDA, was never permitted.
It's just the industry got away with it until
the FDA called them the that it is associated
with increased amount of drinking, heavy drinking
binge episodes, so heavier drinking, more
frequent heavy drinking, and an increased
risk of serious alcohol related consequences,
like driving with an intoxicated driver, being
sexually assaulted, assaulting someone else
sexually, and being hurt or injured enough
to need to seek medical attention.
And what we believe is that the alcohol pardon
me, that the caffeine masks some of the cues
that you might get, that you had had too much
to drink, that the caffeine masks that for
the alcohol.
So you're still drunk if you've drunk enough
alcohol to get to be drunk.
But you perceive because of the caffeine that
you're not as drunk as you think you are.
And what you are is been well described as
a wide awake drunk.
And that's a dangerous thing because you think
you're okay and you are not.
Speaker 1: So when we read about people who
go to the E.R.
after combining these types of elements.
And from what I've read, one in ten of those
E.R.
visits leads to a hospitalization.
What is it people are showing up with?
What What is it that leads to them ending
up at the E.R.?
Speaker 2: So what happens is they go to a
drinking situation where they intend to party.
Sometimes they pre-load with a caffeinated
beverage.
Sometimes they consume the caffeine while
they're consuming the alcohol.
Two things happen.
One is that the caffeine starts to wear off
before the alcohol does, because alcohol is
metabolized at a steady state.
It doesn't matter how much you drink.
If you have five beers or ten beers, you're
going to chip away or your liver will at How
much alcohol there is is independent of how
much you drank, you only can metabolize a
certain amount.
Those of us who drink caffeine are aware that
if you have two cups of coffee at 8:00 by
1:00 in the afternoon, you're ready for another
cup of coffee.
Speaker 1: And this is because of the half
life processing of the caffeine versus linear
with alcohol.
Speaker 2: That is 100% correct.
So there's two things that happen.
One is that the that the caffeine starts to
wear off before the alcohol wears off.
The second thing, what that permit you to
do is to stay awake longer.
So if you drink ten beers, you're going to
pass out.
But if you had loaded on a lot of caffeine,
the same amount of alcohol might not make
you pass out.
You keep drinking longer.
So when the caffeine wears off, folks come
into the emergency department basically comatose
because they've drunk far more alcohol than
they would otherwise have been able to tolerate
without passing out, because they have had
the effect of the caffeine keeping them, helping
them to stay awake longer.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Yeah.
You know, anecdotally, I've had experience
with this not in the situation you're describing,
but since I was a kid, I would have a sort
of like vaso vagal episodes where I would
faint.
And as an adult, I had a situation where before
boarding a flight in Rome, I had an espresso
with my girlfriend in the waiting area.
Because it's Rome, right?
I mean, what do I do?
And then on the plane, they served free wine.
I never have alcohol on airplanes.
But I said, I get it's a long flight.
We're watching a movie.
I'll have It was one espresso and one glass
of wine.
I was very dehydrated and I fainted on a plane
and it became a horrible thing.
I needed, you know, 30 days of a heart monitor
to make sure I was okay.
It was just one of these episodes, but that
seems to be another.
And that's also that same combination of how
these things operate, right?
Speaker 2: It is.
And what that would tell you that you as an
individual are susceptible.
Right.
So even though the FDA would say, oh, you
could have up to four strong cups of coffee
every day, you know better because you've
had the experience of mixing one espresso
with one glass of alcohol and your body does
not tolerate it.
Right.
How do you know whether or not you're one
of the susceptible individuals?
You have to have something bad happen.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I figured it out, right?
Yeah.
What are the.
For people who regularly consume either significant
amounts of energy drinks with or without the
alcohol combination.
But in either case, what do we know about
long term health effects?
Speaker 2: So that's a very, very good question.
And one of the things that is challenging
in the research is that human studies on caffeine,
high levels of caffeine over long periods
of time are really limited by two things.
The first is tremendous variation in individual
sensitivity to caffeine and then in the way
the amount in which caffeine, the rate at
which caffeine is metabolized.
So you metabolize caffeine a little bit differently
than I do.
And that's because we're all individuals,
because I'm a woman, you're a man.
You may or may not smoke cigarets You may
or may not be taking medications that would
affect your caffeine metabolism.
And so individuals, even if you had ten individual.
Will sign up for a lab trial going into it
that compounds the study.
And secondly, we we worry long term about
the cardiovascular side effects in particular
and again, about bone density.
And the ability to do the research that would
establish it is ethically constrained.
Yes, the reason particularly so for women
when they're concerned about where there are
concerns about reproductive effects.
Right.
From use of caffeine.
Speaker 1: When we talk about studies that
make claims and this is more general, I think
about coffee than it is about energy drinks
per se.
But I'm curious your thoughts.
You know, drinking 2 to 3 cups of coffee a
day is associated with a longer life span.
Right.
This is a common thing.
And it's sort of like with eggs.
Coffee is good and then it's bad and then
it's good.
And it depends how you test it or you ask
or when.
You know, with anything, food and drink related.
It seems that part of the difficulty is whenever
you're adding or taking something away, you're
always replacing with something else.
And it can be hard to know whether the effect
is from the removal of some or what is the
best science we currently have about those
types of claims, about a couple of cups of
coffee and longevity.
Speaker 2: So what we do know is that healthy,
non-pregnant, non nursing individuals can
include an energy drink or a strong cup of
coffee or two in their daily diet with in
moderation.
So just like you would do anything else in
moderation for healthy, non-pregnant non nursing
individuals.
Caffeine in moderation is thought to be generally
regarded as safe.
And that's what we know.
Speaker 1: Now, that's extraordinarily narrow
language.
It is generally regarded this.
Yeah.
You know, when when my girlfriend when we
were in the process of starting a pregnancy,
she was told by by a doctor that some of the
assistive medications that exist, we don't
currently believe they increase the risk of
reproductive cancers, which again, when I
hear that, I say it sounds like they might.
It sounds like they might.
And so we really don't know.
Speaker 2: We know that it's generally regarded
as safe.
Okay.
That's what we know with the exceptions for
pregnancy, for nursing, for adolescents and
for individuals who might be susceptible,
whoever they are.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Speaker 1: Well, which I guess I guess the
answer is we maybe would like to know more
than we actually do know right now.
Speaker 2: It's true.
Remember that there are constraints around
science that would establish what safe part
of it is, the individual metabolism absorption
of these substances.
And then part of it is the constraints over
long term health effects that are unknown
and that limit our ability to reproduce in
the laboratory what people commonly do in
real life.
Right.
Speaker 1: Last thing I wanted to ask you
about, do you think that so obviously with
the pre-mixed drinks there off the shelf,
it's a regulatory decision that that was made.
When it comes to I mean, you tell me coffee
of different kinds or energy drinks that are
just energy drinks.
Do you think there needs to be more regulation
or government involvement or is it really
just about educating people and making people
aware of the amounts of these things that
they're consuming?
Speaker 2: So you asked my opinion, so I'm
going to give you an opinion.
Yes.
And I and I think it's poppycock that they
are regulated as dietary supplements.
They're they're beverages.
And that was a decision made in the mid 1990s.
The decision that the FDA made about limiting
the caffeine in cola beverages was made in
1959.
And the energy drinks really came onto the
market in the 1990s, particularly late 1980s,
early 1990s, and in the mid 1990s, the FDA
made a decision that said these are dietary
supplements, they're they're not beverages.
And if they were regulated in the same way
as are the can of Coca Cola that you can buy
in the grocery store right next to them, then
that would make more sense to me.
I think it's poppycock.
Speaker 1: And if they were regulated in the
same way as soda, the difference is would
be labeling or also there would be limits
that would be placed.
Speaker 2: Yeah, there would be limits.
So we mentioned guarana and your mama.
Those are both natural sources of caffeine.
And so they are listed as additives to energy
drinks.
They're more caffeine.
Now, I did a little research to prepare for
speaking with you and looked at a couple of
things on the shelf.
And most of them most of the beverages that
I saw do list the amount of caffeine that's
in them.
Okay.
However, there is not.
I just think we would not you would not give,
you know, three or four cups of coffee to
your average 13 year old.
You would not let a kid in high school think
that an energy drink could serve as a sports
drink when they're not.
You would.
And yet that's what goes on.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Wow.
Well, we will see if that ever.
Is there an appetite to change that, do you
think?
It doesn't seem like it.
Or there is.
Oh, okay.
Speaker 2: There is.
And letters have been written by a couple
of senators.
And these.
This goes back a while, though.
Yeah.
Is there a current appetite?
No.
Was there a lot of appetite in the wake of
the research about the health effects of energy
drinks on alcohol?
Yes.
Did that did that stir the pot about the health
effects of energy drinks at all without alcohol?
Yes.
Has that energy and enthusiasm for making
change continued?
It has not over the last decade, and I'm not
sure why that is.
Speaker 1: Understood.
Understood.
We've been speaking with Dr. Mary Claire O'Brien,
professor of emergency medicine at Wake Forest
University School of Medicine.
Thank you so much for your time.
Appreciate your insights.
Speaker 2: You're welcome.
I am impressed with your level of knowledge
about the science of the subject, and you
can call me any time.
Speaker 1: Thank you.